[Music]
foreign
first look at what's on the front pages
as they arrive it's time to see what's
making the headlines with the incoming
director of the onward Think Tank
Sebastian Payne and the editor-in-chief
of the national World Cities Newspaper
group Nancy Fielder so let's see what's
on some of those front pages for you now
a recent wave of murders has prompted
Rishi sunak to pledge to make Britain
streets safer that's according to the
express
the times has word of a pledge from
labor but if elected tackling
anti-social Behavior would be one of
their major priorities
the male believes that the shelving of a
treasury review Into the country's tax
systems is effectively an admission that
the government no longer intends to cut
taxes
according to the guardian families of
dementia patients are voicing their
concern after it emerged that more than
half of residential homes inspected this
year were rated inadequate
and the financial times reports that
Exxon Mobil is suing the European Union
in an attempt to quash a windfall tax
that would cost all companies around 22
billion pounds
a reminder that by scanning the QR code
you'll see on screen during the program
you can check out the front pages of
tomorrow's newspapers while you watch us
and we are joined tonight by Sebastian
Payne and Nancy Fielder welcome to you
both let us start with the express and
this vow by the prime minister
to tackle crime
um committing to making the streets and
homes safe for everybody and this is
after a horrific wave of murders over
Christmas which we've been reporting on
Sebastian
yes there's not a huge amount of this
story that every prime minister you
could imagine over the past couple of
decades is that they want to make the
streets safer and they're going to try
and clamp down on some of the most
egregious and most awful climbs like
those being reported on the front page
of the express but as with all these
things the question is how is it going
to be done where is the money to do this
what are the process to see this through
within the home office now I wish you
soon act has made crime a pretty big
part I would say of his agenda for being
prime minister that I recall when I went
to the G20 Summit with the Prime
Minister for the end Bali he did a
huddle with journalists on the plane
they talked about this on the plane and
Mr sunak gave a very tough line on
climate heart back to what Michael
Howard said in 1995 when he said prison
works and it feels as if that simple as
he wants to get to it's not a huge
amount new in this Express announcement
here but I think the rise in
particularly violent crimes is something
that is a big problem for the prime
minister in 2023 it's some of the
concerns are going to have to turn
around if they've got any hope
whatsoever of winning the next general
elections so it's fine to say they're
able to bring it down they actually say
how am I going to go about doing it yes
the question how is is a big one but but
Nancy can we assume from the Prime
Minister saying that he will ensure
police have the resources to tackle the
criminals that a lot of money is going
to be thrown at this
well I suspect that is how they're going
to try and tackle it oh that's certainly
what they're going to hope the headlines
will say but as we know the number of
police officers on our streets has
fallen consecutively under every single
government and so we're where we are
partly because of political decisions
now they've had recent big recruitment
campaigns but it hasn't really scratched
the surface and also fundamentally it's
great that you're going to punish people
who are doing horrific crimes and we're
seeing some absolutely devastating
murders this Christmas but they've also
taken away Youth Services they've taken
away mental health support in schools
they've taken away fundamental blocks
which help people get to a life which is
what we would say down is down the right
path so there's nothing there to
actually turn it around so that future
Generations are anti-knife prime or
don't want to carry guns they're not
really tackling these problems at the
root and Punishment isn't going to solve
it for future Generations even if it
makes it slightly better now and to be
honest with no evidence that it does it
doesn't seem to help at all so they're
going to have to do some very serious
Reinventing of their own policies if
they really want to make a difference
and change change society
meanwhile the the times tells us that
that labor is declaring itself the party
of Law and Order Sebastian
yes well this is the flip side of this
the the perceived in action by the
government means that labor think they
can try and score some political runs on
this Steve Reed who is the shallow
Justice secretary is given an interview
to the times tomorrow where he wants to
update Tony Blair's very famous slogan
which was tough on crime tough on the
causes of crime Brian said saying it's
going to focus on prevent crime punish
criminals protect victims and I think
that you know on the one hand you can
see the obvious opening with the big
reduction in community orders that have
been put forward in the past decade and
the statistics on the front page the
times tomorrow that says they've halved
in the past decade that's obviously a
big problem for the government something
they're going to want to try and take
advantage of from the labor perspective
but with all these things for labor you
know it comes back to this question that
you know Nancy was alluding to which is
do you throw more money at the problem
do you look at systemic reform the
conservatives have tried to put 20 000
police officers back on the street which
in some respect is just putting back
what was cut by Theresa May when she was
home secretary in the austerity years so
well then this sort of 12 14 year period
exactly where we were in terms of the
number of police officers and I think
it's completely fine to say being tough
on crime being tough on the causes of
crime no one again would dispute that
but the question is why isn't there
confidence in the criminal justice
system where do police need the
resources they've got more on the ground
bodies that's actually happening the
number of police officers who increased
over the past couple of years but are
those resources within the right places
and of course the big backlog we have in
the court system plays into this as well
following the covert pandemic so there's
no easy answers on this but the fact
that Labor's going so big and thinks it
can make such political gain on an area
that is obviously normally for the
conservative so it's just what an
opportunity they think this is to try to
put some clear dividing lines between
them and the government so more of the
detail the shadow Justice secretary
Steve Reed saying that increasing and
strengthening the use of community
sentence says will tackle reoffending
rates and give a voice directly to
victims victims will be able to select
the unpaid work the Defenders carried
out so victims will be seeing Justice
Done
Nancy
yeah and that all sounds really good
doesn't it I mean it does hurt me
slightly when the focus is on what the
slogan's gonna be because if you've just
been burgled or if you're living next to
Europe you don't really care about
slogans do you what you want is action
and that's what we haven't seen
interesting just in the last few months
most police forces have now said that
they will attend or Burger is I mean
it's mind-blowing to think that actually
the vast majority of burgers weren't
attended and if you think that
anti-social Behavior can be tackled
without huge investment and without huge
policies to to systematically change
things it's just not going to happen but
it's it's all it's not just the big
murders and the big headline grabbing
one is it is anti-social Behavior it's
kids who are on the streets because
there's nothing better for them to do
there is so much that needs to change
here and actually neither party is
coming out with really substantial
change and it's a lot about headline
grabbing it's a lot about slogans and
that's not going to make any difference
and hope you would hope it wouldn't win
them elections because people need to
know the detail but Community sentences
are great I think we'd all like to see
people punished and giving back to their
communities when they've taken something
from it in the first place yeah another
slogan just at the the end of the piece
here from labor prevent crime punish
criminals protect victims let's take a
look at the guardian and the new TUC
Chief um he's got some some Stark words
for the Prime Minister Sebastian
yes Paul Novak is taking over from
Francis O'Grady who's been head of the
TUC for quite some time now with an
interview saying the Prime Minister
needs an exit strategy from industrial
disputes who knew that was the case and
I think everyone in politics can see
they need a way out of that but of
course once again something that's
easier said than done but Mr Novak is is
saying that he thinks the government
have overestimated public
um um sympathy with the government's
position as opposed Strikers and saying
this is not about a kind of 1980s
Playbook and it's basically said that
the sunach needs to try and settle them
and in some respects that is obviously
correct now we've just been some reports
over the past 48 hours or so that the
rmt union are close to doing a deal with
the government on the rails strikes that
could be done by the end of January
which will come as a huge relief to many
of the commuters and holiday makers
across the country but still the most
pressing one I think for me the one
that's most tricky where the government
will need to come from is the dispute
with the nurses that there's a huge
amount of public sympathy for their
plight and obviously there was talk over
the um before Christmas about a one-off
payment for the nurses which ultimately
didn't actually sort of go anywhere but
I think
um Mr Novak is is right that obviously
if the government doesn't find a way out
to this it will keep on rolling and
rolling throughout January and there
will be more strikes and the question
with public is sympathy on this is
always a tricky one because up until
this Christmas period people have been
on the side with the strikers they can
see where inflations are they can see
how Under Pressure Public Services have
been but on the other hand if that
disruption keeps on going there's always
tends to be a Tipping Point which is why
I think it's so interesting there's been
these reports of the rmt getting into
deal territory as it's called and trying
to get this thing resolved and I'm sure
Mr sunac wants to do that but he's also
been very clear he's not going to do
double-digit inflate inflation busting
pay rise because that would prolong the
economic issues facing the country at
the moment so an exit strategy well
won't include that yes no absolutely an
exit strategy is needed and one might
think that the word that they need to to
look for is negotiation but that's
something the government have not been
of a mind to do up to this point Nancy
it does seem fairly straightforward when
you're not involved doesn't it if you
don't talk then how are you going to
solve it and this is a really bad look
for a relatively new government I mean
it harks back doesn't it to being so out
of touch during covid and partying well
while lockdown's happening sticking your
fingers in your ears and thinking that
you don't have to treat people like
human beings you don't even have to
listen really really isn't a good look
and I mean the public is just so
massively in support of the NHS workers
perhaps let's know some of the other
strikes but everywhere you go there does
seem to be very vocal support for all of
these strikes and the more and more of
them come the more public support
because this is not a union strike these
are human beings who don't want to be on
strike who don't want to give up a
portion of their already small salary
because they feel they have to do this
to get acknowledgment and reward from
the government so but for to have a
prime minister who is refusing to lead
is a really really bad look and it
hopefully is going to change his mind
because there is no other exit strategy
so negotiation is the only way forward
very quickly well I would just say I
think that has been plenty of
negotiating going on here first of all
the rmt have been in and out of the
department for transport for a long
period of time trying to get a deal even
though this is not their responsibility
you've got to remember there's the train
operating companies who set the pay and
the government has got involved with
that Steve Barkley has had several
rounds of talks with the Royal College
of Nursing so I don't think it's fair at
all to say there have been no Talks Of
course Steve Steve wouldn't talk about
pay though would he
he wouldn't talk about pay because as
you are well aware it's set by the
independent government pay commission
that sets where salaries should be the
only place The Government Can intervene
is looking at working conditions and the
overall employment package so I think
it's not fair to the government just
sitting back and letting this thing go
by they do want this resolved I think
ministers are doing that but what they
are not willing to do is just to get big
price to make it go away which is what
people at the end of the tucs suggest
but it is factual to say that they will
not discuss uh pay as you said because
of the independent pay review body that
they're leaving that up to we must leave
it therefore the moment we're going to
take a break but do stay with us coming
up the male is worried about the
treasury shelving a review Into the
country's tax system we'll discuss that
and more next
[Music]
thank you
welcome back you're watching the Press
preview still with me Sebastian Payne
and Nancy Fielder let us take a look at
the ft and this
story on the front page is to do with
the Italy and the United States imposing
covered restrictions on the Chinese
Travelers Italy's to test all passengers
arriving from China for Coronavirus and
this is following the the upsurge in
covid-19 within China Nancy
yes so I mean this follows changes in
China to the rules um for travel it's
been really really strict for a long
time as we know and it's been absolutely
sort of zero tolerance of travel and
that's changed and so internationally
countries are reacting to this by
bringing in their own measurements to to
stop people or to test people when
they're traveling into other countries
and people are incredibly worried about
new variants new ways of covert the
pulse of vaccines aren't ready for as I
think it was it was pretty automatic
that people would react in this way
whilst China did lift its travel
restrictions and here we are I think we
can only hope um for the best of it it's
been pretty tough in China but the last
thing we want is for it to be spread
around the world again as we've all
previously lived through the lockdowns
haven't we yeah then we read that Japan
and India have also imposed new
requirements for Chinese arrivals
Sebastian
that's right and I think America's
announced just um since these papers
went to press they're going to require a
negative covert test before anyone from
China is allowed to enter and I think
obviously this is a result of China's
ridiculous zero covert policies where
they've essentially tried to clamp down
and lock down any small outbreak
whatsoever of covid over the past couple
of years long after every other country
has moved away in terms of those sorts
of restrictions and but you know it is
now for a consequence of that and
China's faced a huge amount of protests
that um people have been fed up with
this they had to move on from zero
covered but as it reintegrates itself
the rest of the world both in travel
trains economy that's going to have big
impacts well there's the health issue
here if the Chinese economy is properly
starting up again that does risk a whole
wave of inflation hitting the hitting
elsewhere because so far its economic
growth has been quite damp and because
everything's been closed up and locked
down but I think as Nancy said everyone
was just be hoping that it's not too
restrictive and people are still allowed
to get about their lives and that the
pressures of covert on the Chinese
Health System aren't too great yes it
does have a knock-on effect doesn't it
for the rest of the world in Germany
there demands that flights are suspended
um until they're sure that there's no
threat of a new dangerous mutation out
of China and that is the worry that
there could be some further mutation
that that we're not resistant to Nancy
that's right and we all know that there
was our accusations of responding too
slowly originally when sort of covered
well most of us had not heard of it and
yet we went on through it's a completely
turn all our lives upside down so it is
good that they're reacting this way
we've got to react fairly but we have
got to react swiftly
um and I think countries that I should
say there's already sort of half a dozen
countries reacting to it but there will
be more and I suspect we'll see sort of
every country in the world responding in
order to keep it under control because
we all know how horrific it can be
Sebastian II the male and we read of um
plans to show that the treasury review
that the one that was promised under
questi quateng that the chancellor
Jeremy Hunt has seemed to have um
quietly swept under the carpet according
to the mail
yeah I have to confess to someone who
spent the past four years writing about
various tax reviews and the like I
wasn't actually even aware this one
existed but here we are so it turns out
when quasi-autang was Chancellor he
commissioned this review into Britain's
tax efficiency and it would not take a
genius to work out but our tax base
should probably be a bit low than it is
at the moment given that the tax burden
is at a seven decade high but this
review has been uh scrapped by Jeremy
Hunt the current chance they won't be
used to inform the budget in March and
this will happen we'll knock on effects
because many on the right of the
conservative party those who want to see
taxes lower we'll see this as further
Evidence the Sunnah government is not in
favor of cutting taxes because obviously
the burden has risen significantly in
the Autumn statement we saw a couple of
weeks ago following that disastrous many
budget and John Redwood the veteran um
tax cutting you as skeptic is moaning on
the front page saying it would be it
should be an integral part of any future
budget but enthusiastic not why the
government's priorities are right now
and I think that's probably right that
people aren't desperate tax cuts at this
moment what they want is financial
stability that's what we saw in the
Autumn statement and the moment the tax
cuts will probably come the later date
when inflation is lower interest rates
are coming down and the economy is in a
better place but again this is
definitely a political headache for the
Sunnah government